[Music]
it's all from the inside out
but meets all you know you are what you
eat
Heidi Klum dishing on her simple diet
secrets while sporting her sexy swimwear
line at HQ twos grand opening at Ocean
Resort Casino in Atlantic City
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't really have a specific diet I
just need very healthily you know I
start with great smoothies in the
morning I also have four children so we
cook a lot I don't really eat out a lot
I think when you eat out a lot or when
you order foods in a lot then it kind of
gets a little tricky because you don't
know what people are putting in there so
I cook a lot I do three big meals but
really my last one is at 6:00 p.m. I eat
with my kids I think that also helps a
little bit I think when you eat a little
on the earlier side and has time to
digest and I think it is a little bit
better for your body and Heidi is all
about spreading body positivity with her
design I love designing swimsuits and
it's a beach party or a pool party so I
thought that would be the perfect that's
higher for today I try to make swimsuits
for women any shape or size and I also
believe that women should embrace their
shape no matter what shape there is I
think you should love yourself for who
you are
[Music]